It was [? Emmy ?] who explained it best. This is years ago. [? Connie ?] and Emmy were about to have their second child. Connie must have been nine months pregnant already. And their daughter, Maya, was getting nervous about having a new sister.
是Emmy解释得最好。那是几年前的事了。Connie和Emmy快要迎来他们的第二个孩子了。Connie当时肯定已经怀孕九个月了。而他们的女儿Maya对于要有一个新妹妹感到很紧张。
And [? Emmy ?] said, I totally understand it. He said, if Connie were to come home and say, "Honey, I'm going to be bringing home a second husband. He's going to be a little younger than you, a little cuter. I'm going to be spending most of my time with him. But honey, don't worry. I love you just as much." [? Emmy ?] said, I would see through that in a second.
Emmy说，我完全理解。他说，如果Connie回家对我说：“亲爱的，我要带第二个丈夫回家。他会比你年轻一点，可爱一点。我会把大部分时间都花在他身上。但亲爱的，别担心。我依然像爱你一样爱着他。”Emmy说，我一眼就能看穿这种谎言。
Sibling rivalry. When Jack and Lisa had their second child, their first daughter, [? Tarpley, ?] was two and a half, seemed totally cheerful about the new baby. Then about three weeks after the new baby was born, [? Tarpley ?] was at day care. And one of the women at day care asked her, "So how's your little sister doing?" Tarpley looked her straight in the eye and said, "She's dead."
手足竞争。当Jack和Lisa有了第二个孩子时，他们的大女儿Tarpley两岁半，对新来的宝宝似乎完全很开心。但在新宝宝出生大约三周后，Tarpley在日托中心。其中一位阿姨问她：“你小妹妹怎么样了？”Tarpley直视着她的眼睛说：“她死了。”
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, sibling rivalry, stories of people thrown together by fate to squabble inescapably.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天我们的节目主题是手足竞争，讲述人们因命运被强行联系在一起，从而不可避免地发生争吵的故事。
Act One, He Is Heavy, He's My Brother, true tales of sibling horror. Act Two, Drama of the Gifted Child And Her Sister, what happens when your sibling is more talented than you ever dream of being. Act Three, Destiny, a mom records her own daughters fighting, and what she learns in the process. Act Four, Fraternity is Destiny, the story of 100 brothers and their fates together. Stay with us.
第一幕，“他很沉，他是我的兄弟”，关于手足恐怖的真实故事。第二幕，“天才儿童及其姐妹的戏剧”，当你的手足比你梦寐以求的更有天赋时会发生什么。第三幕，“命运”，一位母亲记录了她女儿们的打架过程，以及她在此过程中学到的东西。第四幕，“兄弟情即命运”，讲述100个兄弟以及他们共同命运的故事。请留下来。
Act One, He Is Heavy, He's My Brother. What is it about our own brothers and sisters, that we treat them worse than we would ever treat anybody in our entire lives, anyone? And if you doubt this is true, if you doubt it for a second, we offer these case examples.
第一幕，“他很沉，他是我的兄弟”。到底是什么让我们对待自己的兄弟姐妹比对待生命中遇到的任何人都更糟糕？如果你怀疑这是真的，如果你怀疑哪怕一秒钟，我们提供这些案例。
The very meanest thing would be locking my brother to a flagpole. He was chained to the flagpole for six hours.
最刻薄的事莫过于把我弟弟锁在旗杆上。他被锁在旗杆上六个小时。
He made me eat grass.
他逼我吃草。
I used to play records that I knew she couldn't stand. I'd play them over and over again. And she'd get so frustrated that she'd throw butter knives at me.
我过去常播放我知道她无法忍受的唱片。我会一遍又一遍地放。她会沮丧到拿黄油刀扔我。
He made me drink out of the toilet.
他逼我喝马桶里的水。
She took my doll. Her name was Beanie. And she threw it down the incinerator.
她拿走了我的玩偶。它叫Beanie。她把它扔进了焚化炉。
So my brother comes up to me, and he's like, what's your favorite thing in the entire world? And at the time, my favorite thing in the whole world was this teeny little shell, this little tiger-backed shell that my grandfather had given me for Christmas. So I go down to lunch. I have a tuna fish sandwich. I come back upstairs, go to my room. There's no shell.
我哥哥走到我面前，问我，你在这个世界上最喜欢的东西是什么？当时，我最喜欢的是这个小小的贝壳，那个我祖父圣诞节送给我的小虎纹贝壳。我去吃午饭。我吃了一个金枪鱼三明治。我回到楼上，去我的房间。贝壳不见了。
And I hear my brother calling me from outside. So I go downstairs. I go outside. And there is my brother. And he's holding this string in his fingers, this yellow string.
我听到哥哥在外面喊我。我下楼去。我走到外面。我哥哥就在那儿。他手里拿着一根绳子，一根黄色的绳子。
And on one side of the string is my shell, my little tiger shell. And on the other side of the string are my blue helium birthday balloons. And I'm standing there about 20 feet away from him. And he just opens his fingers. And I watch my shell float up into the wild blue yonder.
绳子的一头系着我的贝壳，我的小虎纹贝壳。另一头是我的蓝色氦气生日气球。我站在离他大约20英尺远的地方。他松开了手指。我看着我的贝壳飘向了广阔的蓝天。
We would take baths together. And a lot of that time was fun time. But there was also some times when we would fight. And I don't remember exactly how it happened. I remember being left by my mother in the bath with my brother. And I pooped in the bathtub. And there was poop floating around in the bathtub. And I somehow convinced him that it was his poop.
我们过去常一起洗澡。很多时候那是快乐时光。但也有几次我们会打架。我不记得具体是怎么发生的了。我只记得母亲把我和哥哥留在浴缸里。我在浴缸里拉了屎。浴缸里漂着屎。我不知怎么说服了他，让他以为那是他拉的。
And they would hold me down. And they would just [SLURPING NOISE] And they would just spill it on you, and in the forehead. It was just sloppy. And they would just do this. They would get it ready. And you could see them getting it ready. And then they'd do just this [SLURPING NOISE] And it would come out of their mouth. But then they'd suck it back up. [SLURPING NOISE] But occasionally, they would just let it go.
他们会把我按住。他们会……（吸吮声）他们会把它倒在你身上，倒在额头上。这太恶心了。他们就这么做。他们会准备好。你可以看到他们准备的样子。然后他们就这样做……（吸吮声）它会从他们嘴里出来。但随后他们又会把它吸回去。（吸吮声）但偶尔，他们会直接把它吐出来。
And he would tie a sheet on me and tell me I could fly like Superman. And he was going to let me test it first by jumping off the barn.
他会给我系上一块床单，告诉我我可以像超人一样飞。他说他要让我先从谷仓上跳下去试试。
And did you jump off the barn?
你真的从谷仓上跳下去了吗？
Yes. I think I broke my collarbone.
是的。我想我摔断了锁骨。
[SLURPING NOISE]
（吸吮声）
Everyone knows this one, with a little brother or little sister. When you're sitting around, and you really are lazy, and you don't want to go somewhere. You don't want to go outside and do your chores, or take the garbage, out or go to the store, or anything like that, there's a little game where you say, "Hey, Josh." My brother's name is Josh. "Hey, if you can go to the store in less than five minutes and buy this, this, and that for me, and you get back within the five minutes time-- I'll time you on this watch-- I'll give you--" whatever, something close to you, like my favorite baseball card or $5 or something.
每个人都知道这个游戏，关于小弟弟或小妹妹的。当你坐在那儿，真的很懒，不想去什么地方时。你不想出去做家务，或者倒垃圾，或者去商店，或者任何类似的事情，有一个小游戏，你会说：“嘿，Josh。”我弟弟的名字叫Josh。“嘿，如果你能在五分钟内去商店买到这个、那个和那个东西，只要你在五分钟内回来——我会用这块手表为你计时——我就给你……”无论是什么，一些你身边的东西，比如我最喜欢的棒球卡或者5美元什么的。
And they get really excited. And they're like, oh yeah. And you, "Go go go." And they just run. You watch. We used to be able to watch my brother just sort of go off into the distance, into the sunset running.
他们会变得非常兴奋。他们会说，哦，太棒了。然后你喊：“快去快去快去。”他们就跑了。你看着。我们以前能看着我弟弟就这样跑向远方，跑进夕阳里。
And he'd always beat the time. He'd get back in three minutes, four minutes. And you'd always be like, "Oh, five minutes and four seconds, tough loss. Next time. You're getting better. You're getting a lot better."
他总是能按时完成。他会在三分钟、四分钟内回来。而你总是会说：“哦，五分钟零四秒，可惜了。下次吧。你做得越来越好了。进步很多了。”
Act Two, Drama of the Gifted Child's Sister. Now, two stories, a little one and a big one, the little one first. Tamar  Brott grew up with an older brother who was a prodigy on the violin and a sister, one year younger than her, who sang, sang so well that now she is an opera singer. Tamar was tone deaf, wanted to sing, but didn't do it very well. She still remembers the parties that her parents would throw when all the kids were still in grammar school.
第二幕，“天才儿童的妹妹的戏剧”。现在，两个故事，一个小故事，一个大故事，先讲小的。Tamar Brott在成长过程中有一个拉小提琴的天才哥哥，还有一个小她一岁的妹妹，唱歌非常好听，现在是一名歌剧演员。Tamar五音不全，但很想唱歌，却唱得不好。她至今还记得父母在孩子们还在读小学时举办的派对。
The climax of each of these parties would be the two of them performing. It would begin with my brother playing a really hard piece on the violin. And then my sister would be brought out. And she was an extremely beautiful child, and extremely small, so the impact was all the greater when she stepped up. I believe she had some sort of high chair she would get into and sing.
这些派对的高潮是他们两个的表演。首先是我哥哥拉一段非常难的小提琴曲。然后我的妹妹会被带出来。她是一个极其漂亮的孩子，而且身材非常矮小，所以当她走上台时，震撼力更强了。我相信她有某种高脚椅，她会坐在上面唱歌。
And the most amazing thing about it was I really am not conscious of who picked her repertoire. But she had these Malvina Reynolds songs that she sang. And they were all very sad and poignant.
最令人惊奇的是，我真的不知道是谁选的曲目。但她唱了这些Malvina Reynolds的歌。它们都非常悲伤和感人。
The one that would always get the guests, that was saved for the end, was this one. And I don't know what it's called. But the lyrics were, "Turn around, and she's two. Turn around, and she's four. Turn around, and she's a young girl going out of the door."
那首总是能打动客人的歌，被留到最后，就是这一首。我不知道它叫什么。但歌词是：“转过身，她两岁了。转过身，她四岁了。转过身，她是一个即将出门的年轻姑娘。”
And she would sing this song. And the guests would weep. It was just [INAUDIBLE]. And the thing that was really quite hideous about it, the most thing that I just can't forgive her for, is the pause she took after-- and she sang in a baby voice, too. And it was like--
她会唱这首歌。客人们会落泪。这简直是……（听不清）。最可怕、最让我无法原谅她的一点，是她在唱完之后的停顿——而且她还用了娃娃音。就像是——
Turn around, and you're two. Turn around, and you're four. Turn around, and you're a young girl going out of the--
转过身，你两岁了。转过身，你四岁了。转过身，你是一个即将出门的……
And she would have this long pause before "door." And you could glance around the room and see the tears just jutting out of these people's heads. It was horrible.
她会在“出门”之前有很长的停顿。你可以环顾房间，看到眼泪从人们的眼眶里涌出来。这太可怕了。
And I think that's a turning point in your life, right then, when you realize you can not compete with a sibling. And that's probably the first time in life you learn that you can not compete. You're never going to be as good. You either accept it, and you're still whole, or you obsess on it.
我想那是我人生中的一个转折点，当你意识到你无法与手足竞争时。这可能是你人生中第一次认识到你无法竞争。你永远不会像他们那么优秀。你要么接受它，保持完整，要么对它产生执念。
This is the thing. These are the kinds of feelings of failure that we usually think that adults are the only ones who have to grapple with, people in their 40s and 50s and 60s, feeling like, "Oh, I'll never be rich. I'll never find true love. I'll never be famous. I'll never do what other people are able to do." And these are kids going through it, without all of the things that we, as adults, have to help us get through those feelings, alcohol, substance abuse, therapy, religion, sudden moves to the opposite side of the country, badly considered marriages to the wrong people.
事情就是这样。这些通常被认为只有成年人——四五十岁、六十岁的人——才需要面对的失败感，比如“哦，我永远不会发财。我永远不会找到真爱。我永远不会出名。我永远无法做到别人能做到的事。”而这些孩子在经历这些，却没有任何我们成年人用来应对这些感受的东西：酒精、药物滥用、心理咨询、宗教、突然搬到全国的另一头、与错误的人仓促结婚。
They're kids, and the facts stare them in the face. I am inferior. And then you just have to deal. Which brings us to the second story in this act, this one from Sandra Tsing Loh, from her book Aliens in America.
他们只是孩子，而事实就摆在眼前。我不如人。你只能面对。这引出了本幕的第二个故事，来自Sandra Tsing Loh的书《美国的异类》。
All I know is one October night in 1976, we changed from ballet people into Nutcracker people. It had been like any other day. My older sister, Kaitlin, and I had eaten the same after-school snacks, Muenster on pumpernickel, V8. We'd worn our Thursday leotards, navy and white V-neck, orange skater skirt. We'd attended our usual classes at the Mahri School of Dance, Ballet 3 in the big studio, Ballet 2 in the little.
我只知道在1976年的一个十月夜晚，我们从芭蕾女孩变成了《胡桃夹子》女孩。那就像任何平常的一天一样。我的姐姐Kaitlin和我吃了同样的放学零食，Pumpernickel面包配Muenster奶酪，还有V8果汁。我们穿着周四的练功服，藏青色和白色的V领，橘色的滑冰短裙。我们参加了Mahri舞蹈学校的常规课程，在大教室上芭蕾3级，在小教室上芭蕾2级。
Now my mother was driving us home in the same blue Ford Fairmont, and she was launching into her usual speech. "Attack, Kaitlin, attack. That's what your fouette needs, attack." Kaitlin, hunched and sullen in her parka, said nothing.
现在我母亲开着同一辆蓝色福特Fairmont送我们回家，她开始发表她那套老生常谈。“进攻，Kaitlin，进攻。这就是你的挥鞭转所需要的，进攻。”Kaitlin穿着派克大衣，缩着肩膀，闷闷不乐，一言不发。
At 16, Caitlin was "the brilliant one," hence the one who most often disappointed. And so she always rode home in the front seat, the better to receive this disappointment. I was always assigned to the darkness and quiet of the back seat, enjoying vanilla finger cookies, far from achievement and its many complications.
16岁的Kaitlin是“那个聪明的孩子”，因此也是最常让人失望的一个。所以她总是坐在副驾驶座上，以便更好地接收这种失望。我总是被分配到后座的黑暗和安静中，吃着香草手指饼干，远离成就及其带来的复杂烦恼。
"What is wrong with you? You are like a noodle, lifeless." Kaitlin set her jaw, turned away. "Sometimes I wonder with you, Kaitlin. Do you even want these lessons? Heaven knows it is not cheap. If ballet is just one big chore, you should let me know. If getting picked by Irina Lichinska to dance in The Nutcracker is not important to you--"
“你怎么了？你就像一根面条，没有生气。”Kaitlin咬紧牙关，转过头去。“有时我真搞不懂你，Kaitlin。你到底想不想上这些课？老天知道这并不便宜。如果跳芭蕾只是一个苦差事，你应该告诉我。如果被Irina Lichinska选中去跳《胡桃夹子》对你来说不重要的话……”
It was the first I'd heard of this. Irina Lichinska was the ballet mistress of the famed Los Angeles Junior Ballet. A Russian expatriate, she had a glamorous, if shady, past.
这是我第一次听说这件事。Irina Lichinska是著名的洛杉矶青少年芭蕾舞团的芭蕾舞老师。作为一名俄罗斯侨民，她有着迷人但阴暗的过去。
Rumor had it she defected from the Bolshoi in the '50s, married a duke, lived in Monaco for 10 years. She knew everyone famous at the ABT. Irina Lichinska was the sort of person who could take an average ballet student at the average Mahri School of Dance and lift her up to--
传闻她在50年代从莫斯科大剧院叛逃，嫁给了一位公爵，在摩纳哥住了10年。她认识ABT（美国芭蕾舞剧院）的所有名人。Irina Lichinska是那种能把Mahri舞蹈学校里的普通芭蕾学生提拔到……
"If getting picked by Irina Lichinska is not important to you--" My sister turned her Grace Kelly profile with its upswept bun back to my mother. "No, it's fine," she closed her eyes tiredly. "I will try to work on the fouettes."
“如果被Irina Lichinska选中对你来说不重要的话……”我的姐姐把她那拥有Grace Kelly轮廓、盘着发髻的头转向我母亲。“不，没关系，”她疲惫地闭上眼睛。“我会努力练习挥鞭转的。”
"What a workout we had in Ballet 2 today," I exclaimed from my position way back in Siberia. "Those leaps we had, I practically broke into a sweat. Did you see, Mama? Real sweat." My mother glanced back over her shoulder and tossed me a bone. "Sure, Sandra, sure. Good. You keep trying."
“我们在芭蕾2级课上练得好极了，”我在后座的“西伯利亚”喊道。“我们练的那些跳跃，我差点都流汗了。你看到了吗，妈妈？真正的汗水。”母亲转过头看了我一眼，丢给我一根骨头。“当然，Sandra，当然。很好。你继续努力。”
I certainly didn't feel I was a bad dancer. At age 13, only three years younger than Kaitlin, I had been studying almost as long as she had. I loved ballet. I loved what I understood to be the true dance part of it, the whirling about the room, mirrors and other dancers spinning around you, kaleidoscopic. I loved the tattered poster of pink satin pointe shoes in the dressing room. "Ballet," it said, "is inspiration."
我当然不觉得我是一个糟糕的舞者。在13岁时，只比Kaitlin小三岁，我学习芭蕾的时间几乎和她一样长。我热爱芭蕾。我热爱我所理解的舞蹈中真实的部分，在房间里旋转，镜子和其他舞者在你周围旋转，如万花筒般。我喜欢更衣室里那张破旧的粉色缎面脚尖鞋海报。“芭蕾，”上面写着，“是灵感。”
What Kaitlin had going for her, as far as I could see, was good form. Passe, attitude, arabesque, they were clean. She seemed to have almost an obsession with cleanliness. In warm ups, other girls would throw themselves into stretching exercises, triple pirouettes, or other showy endeavors.
据我所见，Kaitlin的优势在于动作规范。擦地、阿拉贝斯克，都很干净。她似乎有一种对洁癖的执念。在热身时，其他女孩会投入到拉伸练习、三圈转或其他花哨的动作中。
Kaitlin, by contrast, would stand in front of the mirror and clock through her positions, first, second, third, fourth, fifth, making the tiniest micro-adjustments. It was almost mathematical, like an engineer tweaking a model airplane. And her face, totally aloof. Oh, a Nutcracker role would be wasted on Kaitlin. I, I was the true ballet dancer.
相比之下，Kaitlin会站在镜子前，逐一核对她的舞姿，一位、二位、三位、四位、五位，做着极其微小的调整。这几乎是数学性的，就像工程师在调整一架模型飞机。她的表情完全冷漠。哦，让Kaitlin演《胡桃夹子》简直是浪费。我，我才是真正的芭蕾舞者。
It was the day of the audition. The excitement among the 60 dance students crammed into the Mahri School of Dance, with mothers, had reached frenzy pitch. Even the accessories were hysterical, tiara-ish Swan Lake headbands, chiffon Capezio dance skirts, flashy earrings. One girl had a miniature gold toe shoe hanging from each ear.
试镜的日子到了。挤在Mahri舞蹈学校里的60名舞蹈学生和她们的母亲，兴奋情绪达到了狂热的程度。就连配饰都让人歇斯底里，像蒂亚拉那样的《天鹅湖》头带，雪纺Capezio舞裙，闪亮的耳环。一个女孩耳朵上挂着微型金色脚尖鞋。
"Irina," someone called out. The throng parted and Irina Lichinska emerged. In person, the legendary starmaker stood a mere five foot two. Her 60-something years on this planet had clearly been tough ones.
“Irina，”有人喊道。人群分开，Irina Lichinska出现了。这位传奇的明星制造者本人身高只有5英尺2英寸。她在地球上度过的60多年显然很艰难。
She had dyed, jet-black hair cut in a lank pageboy. She had one roomy eye. Bright red lipstick slashed across her mouth. She wore an oddly mannish trench coat and black boots. She looked like a bag lady.
她染着一头乌黑的齐耳短发。她有一只松弛的眼睛。亮红色的口红在嘴唇上划过。她穿着一件奇怪的男性化风衣和黑色靴子。她看起来像个流浪汉。
"Hello. I am Irina. Ladies, may I introduce Corinna?" From behind Irina stepped a thin-lipped, rail-thin Audrey Hepburn brunette in a wide cream headband. "She will be leading your exercises today. She is expert in the Cecchetti method."
“你好。我是Irina。女士们，我可以介绍一下Corinna吗？”从Irina身后走出来一个嘴唇纤薄、骨瘦如柴、戴着宽宽奶油色头带的奥黛丽·赫本式的黑发女孩。“她今天将带领你们练习。她是Cecchetti教学法的专家。”
The Cecchetti method? What on earth was that? The brisk Corinna stepped forward to demonstrate.
Cecchetti教学法？那是什么鬼东西？精干的Corinna走上前示范。
"And a one, and a two?" Corinna asked, as though it were some deep metaphysical question. She extended her right leg forward. "And a one, and a two," she replied, like that was the whole answer right there, doing a quick releve on her left leg, beating the right twice at the left knee and whipping it out to the side, her left leg spasming upward into another quick releve before going into a deft 180-degree pivot.
“一，二？”Corinna问，仿佛这是一个深奥的形而上学问题。她右腿向前伸。“一，二，”她回答，好像那就是全部答案，在左腿上快速做一个半脚尖起立，右脚在左膝盖处拍打两次，然后甩向侧面，左腿痉挛般地向上再做一个快速半脚尖起立，然后进入一个灵巧的180度转体。
A taut silence gripped the ragged semicircle of Mahri School of Dance-ers. Faces were white. This wasn't ballet. This was algebra.
一阵紧张的沉默笼罩了Mahri舞蹈学校女孩们组成的半圆。脸色惨白。这不是芭蕾。这是代数。
"All right," Corinna said. "In groups of eight, then." Eight stalwart Ballet 3 students stepped forward. The pianist began the intro. You could feel an audible breath.
“好了，”Corinna说，“八人一组。”八名勇敢的芭蕾3级学生走上前。钢琴师开始了前奏。你可以听到一阵明显的吸气声。
And then seven girls plunged fatally off in different directions, soldiers falling before the enemy's gun. The Cecchetti method had slayed them. But one person stood fast, Kaitlin.
然后七个女孩在不同方向坠毁，就像在敌人枪口下倒下的士兵。Cecchetti教学法消灭了她们。但有一个人站住了，Kaitlin。
There she stood in the center, steely as a weather vane, precise as a clock. She was beating the right leg at the left knee, whipping it out, doing a quick releve, deftly moving into the pivot. Her limbs were chiseled, elegant, clear.
她站在中心，像风向标一样坚定，像时钟一样精准。她用右腿击打左膝，甩出，快速半脚尖起立，灵巧地转体。她的四肢轮廓分明、优雅、干净。
In that moment, I realized that what I couldn't do was that. For all my jumping, whirling, and half-split, I'd never be able to grasp that. That was the elusive thing that made one girl stand out from 100. It was talent, the very face of talent.
那一刻，我意识到我做不到的就是那个。尽管我跳跃、旋转、做半劈叉，但我永远无法领会那个。那就是让一个女孩从100个人中脱颖而出的东西。那是天赋，天赋的真实面目。
The question was not which role to give to Kaitlin, but how many. My mother related this in a tumble as we drove home in the blue Ford Fairmont. Irina had thought Spanish Princess. Corinna had felt they needed Kaitlin to lead the Mirlitons. The flowers, too, needed help. And how about the Snow Queen, or maybe even Sugar Plum Fairy?
问题不在于给Kaitlin什么角色，而是给多少个。当我们开着蓝色福特Fairmont回家时，母亲兴奋地一股脑说了出来。Irina想让她演西班牙公主。Corinna觉得需要Kaitlin来领舞《芦笛舞曲》。花儿们也需要帮助。那雪之女王呢，或者甚至是糖果仙子？
But Sugar Plum Fairy was an advanced, technical role, usually danced by someone on leave from the ABT. On the other hand, if done well, it could lead Kaitlin to New York. In New York was Baryshnikov, Lincoln Center. My mother went on and on, her voice soaring, cresting, swooping. Baryshnikov, Lincoln Center, New York, these were words none had ever dared breathe before in the Fairmont.
但糖果仙子是一个高级的技术角色，通常由ABT请假的人来跳。另一方面，如果跳得好，可以把Kaitlin送往纽约。在纽约有巴兰钦，有林肯中心。母亲滔滔不绝，声音高昂、起伏、跳跃。巴兰钦、林肯中心、纽约，这些词在Fairmont车里是从未有人敢提起过的。
Kaitlin did not smile, but her face seemed to shine in the street lamps that night. New York, I thought, New York. God, she was really that good.
Kaitlin没有笑，但那天晚上她的脸在路灯下似乎在发光。纽约，我想，纽约。天哪，她真的有那么好。
Irina had just one question for my mother. "How are Kaitlin's fouettes?" "Coming along very well, very well, indeed," had been her bold reply. Kaitlin's face contorted into a hideous mask. "Fouettes," she cried out, "No. You know that's the one thing I can't do. I always fall backwards."
Irina对我母亲只有一个问题。“Kaitlin的挥鞭转怎么样？”“进展得非常好，真的非常好，”这是她大胆的回答。Kaitlin的脸扭曲成了一个可怕的面具。“挥鞭转，”她大喊，“不。你知道这是我唯一做不到的动作。我总是向后倒。”
But my mother had an answer for everything. "All you need," my mother pushed on, "is a little more attack. That is all. Just like I've been telling you." "Why do I have to be the Sugar Plum Fairy? Why can't I just do the Spanish dance or the Mirlitons?"
但母亲对一切都有答案。“你所需要的，”母亲继续推销，“只是更多的进攻性。就是这样。就像我一直告诉你的。”“我为什么必须成为糖果仙子？为什么我不能只跳西班牙舞或者《芦笛舞曲》？”
"We will work on it at home. We will do that spotting exercise in the kitchen, every night." "Oh, no," Kaitlin repeated, suddenly looking old and tired.
“我们会在家里练习。我们每晚都要在厨房里做那个定点练习。”“哦，不，”Kaitlin重复道，突然显得苍老而疲惫。
"Are you eating again, Sandra?" My mother turned abruptly. "Uh, yeah," I replied, quickly swallowing my vanilla finger. "Just a cookie. Just a couple. I didn't finish them."
“你又在吃东西吗，Sandra？”母亲突然转过身。“呃，是的，”我回答，迅速咽下我的香草手指饼干。“只是一个饼干。就两块。我没吃完。”
"Sandra, dear, you need to start thinking about just having a piece of fruit after class. You're getting to be a big girl, quite big. Poor Sandra. Well, your grandmother always said you had good, solid legs, legs an empire could stand on."
“Sandra，亲爱的，你需要开始考虑课后只吃一个水果。你快变成大姑娘了，相当大了。可怜的Sandra。好吧，你祖母总是说你有结实的腿，能撑起一个帝国的腿。”
"What?" I gasped. "What are you saying? I'm big? Do you mean I'm fat?"
“什么？”我倒吸一口凉气。“你在说什么？我很大？你是说我胖吗？”
"Spot and spot." My mother's voice drifted in from the kitchen. "Spot and spot."
“定点，再定点。”母亲的声音从厨房飘过来。“定点，再定点。”
It was two weeks later. Kaitlin had been training with Corinna by day, drilling with my mother by night. Kaitlin's big fouette showdown with Irina was tomorrow. "It's no use," I could hear Kaitlin reply. "If you just have a little more confidence in yourself-- spot and spot. Spot and spot."
那是两周后。Kaitlin白天跟着Corinna训练，晚上跟着我母亲操练。Kaitlin与Irina的挥鞭转大决战就在明天。“没用的，”我能听到Kaitlin回答。“如果你对自己有一点点信心——定点，再定点。定点，再定点。”
I lounged in the dark living room. I was eating peanut butter. I would plunge my finger into the jar, lick. Plunge and lick. Plunge and lick. In 20 minutes, I consumed half a jar and felt sick. But what did it matter? I was fat.
我懒洋洋地躺在黑暗的客厅里。我在吃花生酱。我把手指伸进罐子里，舔。伸进去，舔。伸进去，舔。20分钟内，我吃了一半罐子，感觉想吐。但那有什么关系呢？我胖啊。
On the family scale, under the harsh glare of the fluorescents, I had discovered that I weighed 137 pounds at age 13. It was like a weird dream. How had this grotesque transformation happened?
在日光灯刺眼的照耀下，在家庭秤上，我发现我13岁时体重是137磅。这就像一场奇怪的梦。这种荒诞的转变是怎么发生的？
"Sandra?" Oh. It was just Kaitlin. "I'm glad you get to be a flower." She sat down in the darkness with me. "Are you excited?" "Oh, I suppose so. There are what, 25 of us? I just hope they find enough pink tulle in the city to cover us all."
“Sandra？”哦。是Kaitlin。“很高兴你能演花。”她坐在黑暗中陪我。“你兴奋吗？”“哦，我想是的。我们有25个人，不是吗？我只希望他们在城里能找到足够的粉色薄纱覆盖我们所有人。”
All of us fat girls had been jettisoned into the vegetable kingdom. In the hellish [? bulges, ?] in the cruel, Darwinian pecking order of The Nutcracker, only the "Waltz of the Flowers," the lowest rung, would do for us. Any girl who could pull a pair of tights over her hips could be a flower.
我们所有胖女孩都被扔进了植物王国。在《胡桃夹子》残酷的达尔文式等级制度中，只有最低级的“花之圆舞曲”适合我们。任何能把紧身裤拉过臀部的女孩都可以是花。
"I'm going to be humiliated tomorrow," Kaitlin said suddenly. "What?" "No, it's true." I could see her Grace Kelly profile perfectly silhouetted. Her words were said with almost clinical detachment.
“明天我会丢脸的，”Kaitlin突然说。“什么？”“不，是真的。”我能清晰地看到她那Grace Kelly轮廓的侧影。她说这些话时带着近乎临床的冷漠。
"My spotting isn't good, not yet. I think it's because my weight is falling backward on the releve. It's something I have to relearn, but not in three weeks."
“我的定点做得不好，还没练好。我想是因为我的重心在半脚尖起立时向后倾了。这是我必须重新学习的东西，但在三周内做不到。”
And she was right. After all, Kaitlin was the genius. She knew ballet. She understood it. But one thing Kaitlin was wrong about, she would not humiliate herself the next day.
她是对的。毕竟，Kaitlin是天才。她懂芭蕾。她理解它。但Kaitlin有一件事错了，她第二天并不会丢脸。
The pianist began the Sugar Plum Fairy intro as usual.
钢琴师像往常一样开始了糖果仙子的前奏。
Um plum, um plum, um plum, um plum.
嗯，李子，嗯，李子，嗯，李子，嗯，李子。
On cue, Kaitlin whipped her right leg out and began her painful but impressive hopping on one pointe sequence. She neatly ended the phrase with a deft skip, turn, plie, to murmurs of approval from the throng of watching students and mothers.
按预定动作，Kaitlin把右腿甩出，开始她那痛苦但令人印象深刻的单脚尖跳跃序列。她以一个灵巧的跳跃、转体、屈膝结束了乐句，赢得了观看的学生和母亲们的低声赞许。
"That's lovely, darling, lovely," Irina called out, clapping her wrinkled hands together. Two short stag leaps done with perfect landings, a gentle sigh. And then, buoyed by the music, Kaitlin boureed toward the center, the site of the dreaded fouette sequence.
“真可爱，亲爱的，真可爱，”Irina大声说，拍着她满是皱纹的双手。两个短促的跳跃，着地完美，一声轻柔的叹息。然后，在音乐的推动下，Kaitlin向中心滑步而去，那是可怕的挥鞭转序列的地点。
But instead of launching into her turns, that day, Kaitlin kept boureeing and boureeing. Her speed picked up. She broke into a run.
但那天，Kaitlin没有发动旋转，而是不停地滑步。她的速度加快了。她跑了起来。
"Darling?" Irina called out. A murmur arose from the crowd. The pianist looked nervously over her shoulder but kept playing, because there was no stopping Kaitlin.
“亲爱的？”Irina喊道。人群中传来一阵低语。钢琴师紧张地看了看肩膀，但继续弹奏，因为没有人能阻止Kaitlin。
She kept running about the studio, running, just like in Giselle 's mad scene. She was shaking her head, no, no, no. And then giving one final, riveting leap, Kaitlin ran out the door, down the stairs, and caught the bus home.
她在工作室里不停地跑，跑，就像《吉赛尔》中的疯癫场景一样。她摇着头，不，不，不。然后在一个最终的、引人注目的跳跃后，Kaitlin跑出了门，下了楼梯，坐上公交车回了家。
I didn't have the courage to run from The Nutcracker. I stayed, was zipped into my huge, pink costume, ate my sandwiches, did my waltz. But I, too, was changed, because I'd seen that pure, steely thing inside Kaitlin.
我没有勇气逃离《胡桃夹子》。我留了下来，被拉上巨大的粉色戏服，吃了三明治，跳了我的圆舞曲。但我，也改变了，因为我看到了Kaitlin内心那种纯粹、钢铁般的东西。
Call it character, call it stubbornness. Whatever it was, it led to the true revelation of my 13th year, that a kind of integrity existed that was invisible to the world, that certain acts of courage reap no earthly rewards, that somewhere in the darkness of the audience, my sister sat, bearing her terrible burden, knowing all. Slowly, I waltzed with my 24 compatriots, our hair curled, our faces rouged, in the bright glare of the footlights.
叫它性格，叫它固执。无论那是什么，它导致了我13岁那年真正的启示，即存在一种对世界不可见的完整性，某些勇气行为不会获得世俗的回报，在观众席的黑暗中，我的姐姐坐在那里，承受着她可怕的重担，心知肚明。我慢慢地与我的24个同伴共舞，头发卷曲，脸颊涂红，在舞台灯光的强烈照耀下。
Sandra Tsing Loh, stories from her book, Aliens in America.
Sandra Tsing Loh，来自她的书《美国的异类》。
Coming up, Luke, it is your destiny. Now why doesn't Princess Leia say that instead of Darth Vader? Well, maybe she should. Why? In a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，Luke，这是你的命运。为什么莱娅公主不这么说，而是达斯·维达这么说呢？嗯，也许她应该。为什么？一分钟后，来自国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, sibling rivalry. We've come to Act Three of our show, Destiny.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周我们的节目，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你各种各样的故事。今天的节目，手足竞争。我们来到了节目的第三幕，命运。
Well, Deb Monroe has two daughters. And they're a pretty typical family, except for one thing. Deb does some radio reporting, and so she has professional tape equipment lying around the house, and was willing to record her daughters fighting for our program.
Deb Monroe有两个女儿。她们是一个非常典型的家庭，除了有一点不同。Deb做一些广播报道，所以她家里有专业的录音设备，并且愿意为我们的节目录制她女儿们打架的声音。
Her daughter Alexandra is five years old. Michaela is six and a half. Michaela believes that as the older child, she should get special rights and privileges. Alexandra believes otherwise. And they start measuring who is ahead from the time they wake up in the morning. Who's getting more cereal, who's getting more juice, who gets closer to the microphone.
她的女儿Alexandra五岁。Michaela六岁半。Michaela认为作为较大的孩子，她应该享有特殊的权利和优待。Alexandra则有不同的看法。她们从早上醒来就开始衡量谁占了上风。谁得到的麦片多，谁得到的果汁多，谁离麦克风更近。
Don't.
别这样。
It's not fair. Alex got the microphone. Why does she have to hold it when she's talking, and she holds it up to my mouth? It's not fair. Alex got--
这不公平。Alex拿到了麦克风。为什么她说话时必须拿着它，而且她把它举到我的嘴边？这不公平。Alex拿到了……
Well, it doesn't matter.
嗯，没关系。
Have you observed, does each of them have her own style of tormenting the other one?
你有没有观察到，她们每个人是否有自己折磨对方的方式？
Mm-hmm. The older one likes to control and minimize the achievements of the younger one, but in a very insidious way. So you have to really listen to what she's saying.
嗯。大的那个喜欢控制并贬低小的那个的成就，但方式非常阴险。所以你必须仔细听她到底在说什么。
Like what do you mean?
你指的是什么意思？
Like she'll say, "Boy, Alexandra, you're doing really great on your piano lessons. And if you try really hard for the next two years, you're going to be as good as I am." And it sounds superficially like she's complementing her sister, but she's not. She's asserting her dominance.
比如她会说，“天哪，Alexandra，你的钢琴课练得真棒。如果你在接下来两年里努力练习，你就会和我一样好。”表面上听起来她是在夸奖妹妹，但其实不是。她在维护自己的统治地位。
The other one is more likely to just annoy the older sister. Like when Michaela had her big meltdown, because she wanted to--
小的那个则更容易只是惹恼姐姐。比如Michaela大崩溃的时候，因为她想……
Michaela is the older one.
Michaela是大的那个。
The older one. Her favorite song is "Sweet Dreams" by the Eurythmics. And she thinks it's her song. And she likes to sing it. And she doesn't like her little sister to sing it at the same time.
大的那个。她最喜欢的歌是Eurythmics的《Sweet Dreams》。她认为那是她的歌。她喜欢唱这首歌。她不喜欢妹妹在同一时间唱。
And the little one knows that. And so the little one went around the coffee table singing, "Sweet dreams are made of these," over and over and over.
小的那个知道这一点。所以小的那个绕着咖啡桌唱着：“Sweet dreams are made of these”，一遍又一遍，没完没了。
Alex, please stop. I'm asking you. Can you even hear me? It's annoying.
Alex，求你了，停下。我在求你。你能听见我说话吗？这很烦人。
--to disagree.
……不同意。
Alex, stop.
Alex，停下。
Sweet dreams are made of these.
Alex. Mom, do something.
Alex。妈妈，管管她。
Did anything surprise you about what you found when you started taping?
当你开始录音时，你发现的什么事情让你感到意外吗？
Because I had the microphone in my hand, I became someone else. I was not Mommy. I was just watching, watching to see what would happen.
因为我手里拿着麦克风，我变成了另一个人。我不再是妈妈。我只是在观察，观察会发生什么。
And I was able to see things that I hadn't seen before. I hadn't really noticed that Michaela abdicates all power, and that she's totally incapable of ignoring her sister, and that her sister is so calculated, that Alexandra can remain in control.
我能看到我以前没看到的东西。我没太注意到Michaela放弃了所有权力，她完全无法忽视她的妹妹，而她的妹妹如此精明，Alexandra可以保持控制。
--my songs. Alex.
……我的歌。Alex。
It did not bother Alexandra at all that her sister had just come undone.
妹妹崩溃这件事对Alexandra根本没有任何影响。
Sweet dreams are made of these.
OK, Michaela.
好了，Michaela。
I'm getting frustrated. I asked her nicely. She--
我很沮丧。我好言相求。她……
Come here. Come here, sweetheart.
过来。过来，亲爱的。
Sweet dreams are made of these. Who in the world will disagree? Travel the world and seven seas. Who in the world--
Sweet dreams are made of these. Who in the world will disagree? Travel the world and seven seas. Who in the world……
She was so gleeful that she had got to the microphone first. She won. Fight was over.
她非常高兴自己先抢到了麦克风。她赢了。争吵结束了。
Wow.
哇。
Ding, ding, ding.
叮，叮，叮。
What does each of them try to accomplish when they fight? What is it about the other one that's just getting under their skin? What is it about?
她们在争吵时试图达到什么目的？对方身上有什么地方让她们如此不爽？这是关于什么的？
I think it's an assertion of power and dominance. Both of them want to be the one calling the shots.
我认为这是对权力和统治地位的宣示。她们俩都想当那个发号施令的人。
You're not the boss of me, Michaela Monroe.
你不是我的老板，Michaela Monroe。
Fight for the number one spot. And there is no number one spot. They're siblings.
争夺第一名的位置。但根本没有第一名。她们是手足。
There will never be a number one spot. They're not totally equal. But there is no number one.
永远不会有第一名的位置。她们并不完全平等。但也没有第一名。
What you're saying, in a way, is that they're fated to fight, because it's fated for each of them to want to feel that sense of control and dominance.
你的意思是说，她们注定要争吵，因为她们每个人都注定想要感受到那种控制和统治感。
Yes. And I think that's natural. I think that's totally natural. I think as soon as you begin to suspect that there's something weird or strange about it, we can give kids a lot of hangups.
是的。我认为那是自然的。我认为那是完全自然的。我想一旦你开始怀疑这有什么古怪或奇怪的，我们反而会给孩子带来很多心理阴影。
It's hurting my ears.
我的耳朵好痛。
Sweet dreams are made of these. Who in the world can disagree. Travel the--
Sweet dreams are made of these. Who in the world can disagree. Travel the……
Deb Monroe reports for PRI's Marketplace and for various parenting magazines.
Deb Monroe为PRI的《Marketplace》和各种育儿杂志撰稿。
Everybody's looking for something. Some of them want to use you. Some of them want to used by you.
每个人都在寻找某种东西。有些人想利用你。有些人想被你利用。
Act Four, Fraternity is Destiny. If it is our destiny, our natural destiny, to fight with our siblings as children, so what happens when we grow up? Donald Antrim reads this excerpt from his book, The Hundred Brothers.
第四幕，“兄弟情即命运”。如果作为孩子与手足争吵是我们的命运，是我们自然的命运，那么当我们长大后会发生什么呢？Donald Antrim朗读他书中的片段，《百个兄弟》。
My brothers Rob, Bob, Tom, Paul, Ralph, Phil, Noah, William, Nick, Dennis, Christopher, Frank, Simon, Saul, Jim, Henry, Seamus, Richard, Jeremy, Walter, Jonathan, James, Arthur, Rex, Bertram, Vaughan, Daniel, Russell, and Angus, and the triplets, Herbert, Patrick, and Jeffrey, identical twins Michael and Abraham, Lawrence and Peter, Winston and Charles, Scott and Samuel, and Eric, Donovan, Roger, Lester, Larry, Clinton, Drake, Gregory, Leon, Kevin, and Jack, all born on the same day, the 23rd of May, though at different hours and separate years. And the caustic graphomaniac, Sergio, whose scathing opinions appear with regularity in the front of book pages of the more conservative monthlies. And Albert, who is blind, and Siegfried, the sculptor in burning steel.
我的兄弟们Rob, Bob, Tom, Paul, Ralph, Phil, Noah, William, Nick, Dennis, Christopher, Frank, Simon, Saul, Jim, Henry, Seamus, Richard, Jeremy, Walter, Jonathan, James, Arthur, Rex, Bertram, Vaughan, Daniel, Russell, 和 Angus，还有三胞胎Herbert, Patrick, 和 Jeffrey，同卵双胞胎Michael 和 Abraham，Lawrence 和 Peter，Winston 和 Charles，Scott 和 Samuel，还有Eric, Donovan, Roger, Lester, Larry, Clinton, Drake, Gregory, Leon, Kevin, 和 Jack，都在同一天出生，5月23日，尽管是在不同的时间，不同的年份。还有尖刻的狂草癖患者Sergio，他的尖锐观点经常出现在更保守的月刊的书评页前沿。还有盲人Albert，以及灼烧钢铁的雕塑家Siegfried。
And clinically depressed Anton, schizophrenic Irv, recovering addict Clayton, and Maxwell, the tropical botanist, who since returning from the rainforest has seemed a little screwed up somehow. And Jason and Joshua and Jeremiah, each vaguely gloomy in his own lost boy way. And Eli, who spends solitary, wakeful evenings in the tower, filling notebooks with drawings, the artist's multiple renderings for a larger work, portraying the faces of his brothers, including Chuck the prosecutor, Porter, the diarist, Andrew, the civil rights activist, Pierce, the designer of radically unbuildable buildings, Barry, the good doctor of medicine, Fielding, the documentary filmmaker, Spencer, the spook with known ties to the State Department. Foster, the new millennium psychotherapist, Aaron, the horologist, Raymond, who flies his own plane.
还有临床抑郁症患者Anton，精神分裂症患者Irv，康复中的瘾君子Clayton，以及Maxwell，那位热带植物学家，自从从雨林回来后，不知怎么看起来有点不对劲。还有Jason, Joshua, 和 Jeremiah，每个人都以自己迷失男孩的方式显得有些阴郁。还有Eli，他独自在塔楼里度过清醒的夜晚，在笔记本上画满了画，作为艺术家为大型作品准备的多种渲染图，描绘他兄弟们的脸，包括检察官Chuck，记录员Porter，民权活动家Andrew，激进的不可建造建筑的设计师Pierce，医学博士Barry，纪录片制片人Fielding，与国务院有已知联系的间谍Spencer。新千年的心理治疗师Foster，钟表师Aaron，驾驶自己飞机的Raymond。
And George, the urban planner, who, if you read the papers, you'll recall, distinguished himself not so long ago with that innovative program for revitalizing the decaying downtown area, only to shock and amaze everyone, absolutely everyone, by vanishing with a girl named Jane and an overnight bag packed with municipal funds in unmarked hundreds. And all the young fathers, Seth, Rod, Vidal, Bennett, Dutch, Bryce, Alan, Clay, Vincent, Gustavus, and Joe. And Hiram, the eldest,
还有城市规划师George，如果你读过报纸，你会记得，不久前他凭借那个振兴衰败市中心的创新项目大放异彩，却让所有人，绝对是所有人感到震惊和惊讶，因为他和一个叫Jane的女孩以及一个装满市政资金、面额为未标记的百元钞票的过夜包一起失踪了。还有所有年轻的父亲们，Seth, Rod, Vidal, Bennett, Dutch, Bryce, Alan, Clay, Vincent, Gustavus, 和 Joe。还有长子Hiram，
Zachary, the giant, Jacob, the polymath, Virgil, the compulsive whisperer, Milton, the channeler of spirits who speak across time. And the really bad womanizers, Steven, Denzel, Forrest, Topper, Temple, Lewis, Mongo, Spooner, and Fish. And of course our celebrated, perfect brother Benedict, recipient of a Medal of Honor from the Academy of Sciences for work over 20 years in chemical transmission of sexual language in 11 types of social insects.
巨人Zachary，博学家Jacob，强迫性窃窃私语者Virgil，跨越时间与灵魂沟通的渠道者Milton。还有那些极其糟糕的拈花惹草者Steven, Denzel, Forrest, Topper, Temple, Lewis, Mongo, Spooner, 和 Fish。当然，还有我们备受赞誉、完美的兄弟Benedict，因其20年来在11种社会性昆虫的性语言化学传递方面的研究工作而获得了科学院颁发的荣誉勋章。
All of us, except George, about whom there have been many rumors, rumors upon rumors-- he's fled the vicinity. He's right here under our noses. He's using an alias, or maybe several. He has a new face, that sort of thing. All my 98, not counting George, brothers and I recently came together in the red library and resolved that the time had arrived, finally, to stop being blue, put the past behind us, share a light supper, and locate, if we could bear to, the missing urn full of the old [BLEEP]ers ashes.
我们所有人，除了George，关于他已经有很多传言，传言之上的传言——他逃离了附近。他就躲在我们的眼皮底下。他用了一个假名，或者可能好几个。他有了一张新脸，诸如此类。我和我所有的98个兄弟（不包括George）最近在红色图书馆聚在一起，并决定，终于，现在是时候停止忧郁，把过去抛在脑后，共进一顿清淡的晚餐，并找到，如果我们能忍受的话，那个装着旧[哔]灰烬的遗失骨灰盒。
The red library walls were haunted by shadows and light cast from a multitude of low wattage reading lamps that haloed the tables on which they sat. "I hate this room. It stinks of death," whispered Virgil, wedged beside me on a loveseat. "Lighten up, I told him."
红色图书馆的墙壁被从摆放阅读灯的桌子上投射出的阴影和光线所笼罩。Virgil蜷缩在我的双人沙发旁低语：“我讨厌这个房间。它散发着死亡的气息。”“放轻松，”我告诉他。
A line of our brothers scuffed past us in search of places to sit. The library was filling with male energy and low sounds of voices saying, "Hey, man. Scoot over and make space." Soon it would be standing room only. The musty air would grow lush with our smells of sweat, shaving lotions, exhaled humid breaths. God help us.
一排我们的兄弟从我们身边经过，寻找坐的地方。图书馆里充满了男性的能量，以及那种低沉的声音，说着：“嘿，伙计。挪一挪，腾点地方。”很快这里就只能站着了。霉味浓郁的空气中混合着汗水、剃须水、呼出的潮湿气息。上帝救救我们。
No one was altogether certain who'd last seen the urn. Jason once, long ago, reported a sighting over near where maps of the world are stored in drawers. But it wasn't, it turned out, there. And some time back, Paul suggested looking in the gloomy alcove packed with patriotic music hall songs in their archival boxes. A thorough search turned up nothing.
没有人完全确定是谁最后看到了那个骨灰盒。Jason很久以前曾报告说在存放世界地图的抽屉附近看到过。但结果证明，它不在那里。很久以前，Paul建议在存放爱国音乐厅歌曲的档案盒所在的阴暗壁龛里找找。彻底搜索后一无所获。
"It's nice to have everyone together again, isn't it?" a voice near me said. I turned and saw in the shadows a man bearing flowers. This man said, "All the old faces, all the familiar voices. Hello? It's me, Doug. It's William." "William."
“大家聚在一起真好，不是吗？”我身边的一个声音说。我转过身，在阴影中看到一个带着花的人。这个人说：“所有的老面孔，所有熟悉的声音。你好？是我，Doug。是William。”“William。”
"Don't be frightened. I brought these," he said, stepping partway out from darkness with pale flowers held before him. "Lilies brighten a room." "Yes," I agreed.
“别害怕。我带了这些，”他说，从黑暗中走出来，手里拿着苍白的花朵。“百合花能点亮房间。”“是的，”我同意道。
"Take them." "Me?" "Put them on a table, somewhere in the light, where people can enjoy them."
“拿着它们。”“我吗？”“把它们放在桌子上，在光亮处，人们可以欣赏它们的地方。”
"You brought them, William. Wouldn't you like to find a spot for them? Let everyone know you brought flowers. I'm sure it will mean a lot."
“是你带的，William。你不想自己找个地方放吗？让每个人都知道是你带的花。我相信这意义重大。”
"I'd rather not, Doug. I don't think I can bear to talk to everyone right now. Maybe later." "I understand," I said. Then he was gone, behind European folklore and mythology. And I clutched the lilies he had brought for us.
“我还是算了，Doug。我觉得我现在还无法忍受和每个人交谈。也许晚点。”“我理解，”我说。然后他消失在欧洲民间传说和神话书籍后面。我紧紧抓住他为我们带来的百合花。
In the library's open spaces, men tramped singly or with buddies toward the drinks table. Others, already with drinks, stood drinking. They were lucky to have these drinks.
在图书馆的开放空间里，男人们独自或与伙伴们朝着酒水桌走去。其他人，已经拿到了酒，站着喝着。能喝到这些酒真是幸运。
By now, the press around the bar would be enormous, five guys deep at least. It would take an eternity to get served. Clayton and Rob would have poured the last Johnnie Walker Black. And there'd be nothing remaining but Johnnie Walker Red, if that, or maybe Four Roses brand, one of the gallon discounts that are admissible late at night, but which you  never want in the beginning. That's the way life goes around here, the blinking lights, the dry taste in the mouth, the body's craving need for something cold and warm at the same time.
到这个时候，酒吧周围的人一定会很多，至少五层人深。等待服务需要永远。Clayton和Rob会把最后的一瓶Johnnie Walker黑标倒光。剩下的只有Johnnie Walker红标了，如果还有的话，或者可能是Four Roses品牌，那些深夜才允许出现但你从一开始就不想要的廉价大桶装酒。这就是这里的生活方式，闪烁的灯光，嘴里干涩的味道，身体对寒冷和温暖同时的需求。
Out into the milling crowd, I hurled myself out in search of a suitable vase for William's gift. The lilies, with their long, thick stems, their lush, drooping blooms, required a large, heavy vessel, precisely what I could not locate. "Does anyone know where I can find a vase that'll hold these?" I asked a group loitering around the Native American stone tool collection in its metal and glass display case. Dennis shrugged, and Noah said, "Sorry." Jim, who often does not speak even when spoken to-- he's a contemplative Buddhist-- suggested, "Try over by the African masks."
我把自己投向了熙熙攘攘的人群，寻找一个合适的花瓶来装William的礼物。这些百合花，有着长长的粗茎，茂盛、下垂的花朵，需要一个大而沉重的容器，而我恰恰找不到。我问一群闲逛在金属和玻璃展示柜里收集美洲原住民石器的人：“有人知道在哪里能找到花瓶来装这些吗？”Dennis耸了耸肩，Noah说：“抱歉。”Jim，他即使在被询问时通常也不说话——他是一个沉思的佛教徒——建议道：“去非洲面具那边试试。”
Eventually, one of us is going to crash down his glass or an ashtray too hard on that stone tool display table and there will be a mess. I said, "You guys be careful using that as a table, because it isn't designed to support weight." I did not mean to scold my brothers. But what can you do when people have no sense?
最终，我们中的一个人一定会把酒杯或烟灰缸重重地摔在那个石器展示桌上，到时候会是一团糟。我说：“你们几个在那张桌子上要小心，因为它不是为了支撑重量而设计的。”我并不是要责备我的兄弟们。但当人们毫无常识时，你能怎么办呢？
"Seen a vase, anyone?" I asked another bunch as I hurried past their leather sofa and chairs pulled up close in a circle. "Not me," Lewis said. "Maybe on the mantle," said Drake. "I'll try there," I said, then advised, "Take off your shoes if you're going to put your feet on the furniture, because you'll scuff the leather."
“有人看到花瓶了吗？”我匆忙经过围坐在皮革沙发和椅子旁的一群人时问道。“没有。”“也许在壁炉架上，”Drake说。“我去那儿看看，”我说，然后建议道，“如果你要把脚放在家具上，就把鞋脱了，因为你会刮伤皮革。”
The chandelier bulbs overhead flashed off, on, off, on, like playhouse lobby lights signaling act one. I sometimes imagine our red library as a kind of bleak and unruly interpersonal anxiety zone. Emotions heat up, and tempers break out in real disputes that have their roots in 100 contingent histories of the standard childhood competitions, degradations, reparations, punishments, tortures, all the gory excitements of pain and power that seem, in retrospect, so ineluctably linked with childish fantasies about manhood. Screaming and crying were the routine bedlam of our bedtimes, drowning out the crickets and the pounding wind outside, though never drowning out the voices of older brothers, who taunted, "Had enough, you little worms? Father can't help you now."
头顶的吊灯灯泡忽灭忽亮，像信号灯一样预示着第一幕的开始。我有时把我们的红色图书馆想象成一个荒凉、不守纪律的人际焦虑区。情绪升温，争吵在现实纠纷中爆发，这些纠纷植根于100个偶然历史中，关于标准的童年竞争、羞辱、补偿、惩罚、折磨，所有那些痛苦和权力的血腥刺激，在回顾时，似乎与关于男子气概的幼稚幻想紧密相连。尖叫和哭泣是我们睡前惯常的混乱，淹没了外面的蟋蟀声和撞击声，但从未淹没年长兄弟的声音，他们嘲讽道：“受够了吗，你们这些小虫子？父亲现在帮不了你们了。”
I held my eyes closed and pretended to sleep and did nothing, night after night. It grieves me to think back now over old boyish stuff, all the bad times made more bitter in memory by the absence, in this strangling red library, of a serene corner to hide out in, of a comfy chair that gets enough light for reading without strain, of a taste of unstale air to breathe. It's shocking, isn't it, how the dreadful circumstances of one's life grow to feel, simply because one knows them, perfectly normal?
我闭着眼睛假装睡觉，什么也没做，夜复一夜。现在回顾过去这些旧时的男孩琐事让我感到悲伤，所有那些在记忆中因为缺乏一个宁静的角落去躲避、缺乏一把在光线下阅读而不费力的舒适椅子、缺乏一丝新鲜空气去呼吸而变得更加痛苦的糟糕时光。这很令人震惊，不是吗？一个人生活中的糟糕境况，仅仅因为熟悉，就会变得感觉如此正常？
I love my brothers, and I hate their guts. "Me, me," our voices all seem to shout, as if we were not a true community united in blood and spirit, instead, a common mob intent on nothing more than the next drink, the next mouthful of food. I love my brothers, and I hate my brothers.
我爱我的兄弟们，我也恨他们入骨。“我，我，”我们所有人的声音似乎在喊，仿佛我们不是一个团结在鲜血和精神中的真正社区，而是由一群只关注下一杯酒、下一口食物的乌合之众。我爱我的兄弟们，我也恨我的兄弟们。
The long, snaking line of men to the bar was growing less long. Hiram's walker clacked across floorboards, clacked again. It sounded as if Hiram was gouging the floor with a trowel. Each step brought scuffing and digging.
通往酒吧的排队人群正在变短。Hiram的助行器在木地板上发出咯哒声，又发出咯哒声。听起来好像Hiram在用铲子划地板。每一步都伴随着摩擦和挖掘。
Hiram paused on his walker and glared in my direction. His injured hand was swollen and large. He inhaled a shallow breath. He was having trouble, and his mouth was working.
Hiram在助行器上停下来，恶狠狠地盯着我的方向。他受伤的手又肿又大。他浅浅地吸了一口气。他遇到了麻烦，嘴里在嘟囔。
He said, "Where did you get those flowers?" "William." "You should trim their stalks and put them in a vase before they turn brown and die." "I was looking for a vase, actually." "There's one somewhere. You'll find it," he said, as he gripped the walker with his good hand. He heaved himself up, scooted the walker forward on the floor, took another labored step onto the edge of the carpet with its knotted fringe that caught and became tangled as the walker's legs scraped past.
他说：“你在哪弄的这些花？”“William。”“你应该剪掉它们的茎，把它们放进花瓶里，免得它们变黄枯死。”“其实我刚才就在找花瓶。”“肯定有一个。你会找到的，”他说着，用好手抓紧助行器。他撑起自己，把助行器向前推动，在地板上艰难地向前迈了一步，踏在结节流苏边缘的地毯上，助行器腿刮擦过去时，流苏被缠住了。
He said, "I don't know about you, but I'm famished. I could eat a side of beef if I had my original teeth. Remember, always, to care for your teeth, Doug." "I will."
他说：“我不了解你，但我饿坏了。如果我有原来的牙齿，我能吃下一块牛肉。记得，永远要保护好你的牙齿，Doug。”“我会的。”
"Do you floss? Flossing is more important than brushing, I can tell you. Too much vigorous brushing as a young man was my downfall. You scrub away the gums. And before you know it, the roots of your teeth are exposed to the elements, and it murders you to chew. Then, one after another, you lose your teeth, like you lose everything in life." "I'll remember that."
“你用牙线吗？我可以告诉你，用牙线比刷牙更重要。年轻时刷牙太用力是我的败笔。你把牙龈刷掉了。在你意识到之前，你的牙根就暴露在自然环境中，咀嚼会让你痛不欲生。然后，一个接一个，你掉光了牙齿，就像你在生活中失去一切一样。”“我会记住的。”
"Your teeth are your greatest possession. You probably think your greatest possession is your johnson. But it's not your johnson. It's your teeth, especially your two front teeth, these, right here," he said, opening his mouth wide to insert fingers. He touched the teeth in question, the upper incisors.
“你的牙齿是你最大的财富。你可能认为你最大的财富是你的命根子。但不是你的命根子。是你的牙齿，尤其是你的两颗门牙，就是这两颗，”他说着，张大嘴巴把手指伸进去。他触摸了那两颗牙齿，上切牙。
He pointed these out. And when he did, when he touched these dentures, they moved. They were loose in his mouth, insecurely fastened, and slipping off the gum. The effect was grotesque, Hiram's teeth hanging at an angle, wobbling in his mouth, licked by Hiram's tongue and about to fall out, as he commanded, "Stow those flowers in a vase before the petals fall off." "Yes, sir."
他指出了这些。当他这么做时，当他触碰这些假牙时，它们移动了。它们在他嘴里松动了，没有固定好，正从牙龈上滑落。效果极其怪诞，Hiram的牙齿歪斜地挂着，在他嘴里晃动，被Hiram的舌头舔舐着，随时准备掉落，他命令道：“把那些花放进花瓶里，免得花瓣掉光。”“好的，长官。”
Here I was again, in the old, unconscious complicity with Hiram's authoritarian posturing. This happens every time I engage with Hiram. It happens to a lot of us when we engage with him. We feel infantilized. And I invariably promise myself, after taking orders from Hiram, that next time, I'll stand up to him, not obey, and let him get angry if he wants. Tiptoeing around Hiram's anger resolves nothing and only serves to perpetuate a strained and uneasy state of affairs, in which one personality, Hiram's, overwhelmingly influences the general quality of feeling in the room as a whole.
我又回到了那种与Hiram威权姿态的老旧、无意识的共谋中。每次我与Hiram交往，都会发生这种情况。我们很多人与他交往时都会发生这种情况。我们感到幼稚化。在接受Hiram的命令后，我总是向自己保证，下次，我会挺身反抗他，不服从，如果他想生气就让他生气去。绕着Hiram的愤怒走只会导致一事无成，只会加剧一种紧张和不安的局面，其中一种人格，即Hiram的人格，压倒性地影响了整个房间的情绪质量。
Would it be going too far to imagine my own bad moods, my terrors and despairs, and so on, as personalized responses to this room-wide, Hiram-centric emotional atmosphere? Could it then follow that Hiram is himself responsible in large part, unwittingly, presumably, for whatever uncomfortableness we brothers experience when we congregate? Might it be possible, if, in fact, Hiram is the root cause of our squabbles and disputes, might it be possible to drive a wedge through this ancient and pervasive household trepidation-- I don't know what else to call it-- by meeting Hiram's anger with anger? It was in this absurd spirit of revolt against destiny that I now hurled the flowers to the floor before Hiram's walker, before Hiram's feet caged inside the walker's clackety aluminum framework, and said, "Find a vase yourself, you sadist."
如果把我自己糟糕的心情、恐惧和绝望等视为对这种充满整个房间、以Hiram为中心的情感氛围的个性化反应，这会走得太远吗？那么是否可以得出结论，无论我们兄弟在聚会时经历什么不适，Hiram本人（可能是无意的）在很大程度上负有责任？如果事实上Hiram是我们争吵和纠纷的根本原因，那么通过以愤怒应对Hiram的愤怒，是否有可能打破这种古老而普遍的家庭恐惧感——我不知道该怎么称呼它——？正是在这种反抗命运的荒谬精神下，我把花扔在了Hiram的助行器前，扔在了Hiram双脚被锁在助行器咯哒作响的铝制框架内，说道：“自己找花瓶去吧，你这个施虐狂。”
Instantly, I regretted my actions and wanted, needed, to recant and beg forgiveness. Hiram leaned on his walker. He was little and bent over and liver-spotted and lame.
那一瞬间，我后悔了自己的行为，想要、需要去撤回并乞求原谅。Hiram靠在助行器上。他瘦小、佝偻、长着老年斑，而且是个瘸子。
And I was startled to realize once again that I was intensely afraid of him. Throwing the flowers was nothing more than an act of self-disempowerment, an emotional demonstration of the sort that Hiram would never allow himself. I felt awful when Hiram said, "Pick them up."
意识到这一点，我再次感到震惊，我极其害怕他。扔花只不过是一种自我剥夺力量的行为，一种Hiram永远不会允许自己的情感宣泄。当Hiram说“捡起来”时，我感觉糟透了。
It was one of those familiar, deplorable moments. I wished for the dinner bell. No such luck yet.
那是那些熟悉、可悲的时刻之一。我祈祷着晚饭铃声响起。可惜还没有。
In the meantime, there stood Denzel. And next to Denzel was Saul. And next to Saul, and more or less directly behind Hiram, were Aaron and Pierce. And of course, there were other brothers standing around, looking on. And no one among these men wanted to get too close to a fight involving Hiram.
与此同时，Denzel站在那儿。Denzel旁边是Saul。在Saul旁边，也就是Hiram身后，是Aaron和Pierce。当然，还有其他兄弟站在那儿看着。没有一个人想卷入涉及Hiram的争吵。
Hiram leaned forward over the frame of the walker, out over the metal frame. He had me in his sights. He said, "You're full of hate, aren't you, Doug?" "No." "You keep it all bottled up inside, your scorn and your contempt for people. And when you can't control it any longer, it comes flying out. And we have one of our little tragic scenes. Isn't that right?" "No."
Hiram在助行器框架上向前倾斜，越过金属框架。他盯上了我。他说：“你充满了仇恨，不是吗，Doug？”“没有。”“你把它全部装在心里，你对他人的蔑视和蔑视。当你无法再控制它时，它就会爆发出来。然后我们就会上演一出悲剧小场景。不是吗？”“没有。”
"This is a family full of love, Doug. We all love one another here. This whole room is full of love. Too bad you can't feel it, Doug. You can't participate in love because you're busy tearing everybody down. You want to tear us down, and you want to discredit our forefathers." "No."
“这是一个充满爱的家庭，Doug。我们所有人都互相关爱。整个房间充满了爱。真遗憾你感觉不到，Doug。你无法参与爱，因为你忙于贬低每个人。你想贬低我们，你想贬低我们的祖先。”“没有。”
"Don't say no to me, boy. You think that if you find sickness in others, you'll be healthy. You think if you find weakness in others, you'll be strong. Does throwing a bunch of flowers at an old man make you feel strong, Doug?"
“别对我说不，孩子。你以为如果你在别人身上发现疾病，你就会健康。你以为如果你在别人身上发现弱点，你就会坚强。扔花在一个老人身上让你感觉坚强了吗，Doug？”
"No," I whispered. "Speak louder." "No." "Pick up the flowers, Doug."
“没有，”我低声说。“大声点。”“没有。”“捡起花来，Doug。”
Then the 20 chandeliers blinked off again, and everything became a shade darker for an instant. It was like a negative form of lightning, perfect accompaniment to the routine thunder of wind hitting windows. Chuck's dog, Gunner, barked and barked.
然后20盏吊灯再次闪灭，瞬间一切变得更暗了。那就像一种负向的闪电，完美地配合了风撞击窗户的常规雷声。Chuck的狗，Gunner，不停地狂吠。
The Doberman had managed to unsnarl his leash from the art nouveau armchair. And so he was free now, and sprinting in wider and wider circles around the furniture. "Settle down, fellow," Chuck called to the racing dog.
这只杜宾犬成功地从新艺术风格的扶手椅上解开了牵引绳。于是它现在自由了，正在家具周围绕着越来越大的圆圈奔跑。“冷静点，伙计，”Chuck对着奔跑的狗喊道。
I prayed for Gunner to dash toward Hiram and knock him down. "Here, boy." Instead, Gunner charged between couches. Men sidestepped to avoid the onrushing dog. Gunner jumped a coffee table, then disappeared into a narrow aisle of shelves housing geology, natural history, and mineral sciences.
我祈祷着Gunner冲向Hiram并将他撞倒。“来，小子。”相反，Gunner冲进了沙发之间。男人们侧身避开冲过来的狗。Gunner跳过一张咖啡桌，然后消失在存放地质学、自然历史和矿物科学书籍的狭窄过道里。
I had begun a moment or two ago to describe in plain terms the situation as it stood that night with the lilies and with Hiram, our little semi-public showdown that wasn't, in fact, so little. I always charge off the track in moments like these, the bitter moments, I guess you'd call them, and instead begin rendering the scenery and all the extraneous misbehavior of my brothers and their abysmal pets, as if anyone cares. Conflict is the really interesting thing, I've found. Conflict.
几分钟前，我开始用简单的语言描述那天晚上百合花和Hiram的情况，我们那场微小的半公开对峙，其实一点也不微小。在这种时刻，我总是偏离轨道，我想你们会称之为苦涩的时刻，转而渲染周围的风景以及我兄弟们及其糟糕宠物的额外恶作剧，好像有人在乎一样。我发现，冲突才是真正有趣的事。冲突。
Conflict is always so difficult to recount. By difficult, I suppose I mean painful. But also, I mean demanding. The technical aspects of describing true conflict are daunting.
冲突总是很难讲述。所谓难，我想我指的是痛苦。但我也指费力。描述真正冲突的技术细节令人望而生畏。
First, you have to establish your antagonists. It is important to avoid cozy oversimplifications, and to bear down instead on all the obscure and intractable problems of identity and desire that make our lives and our needs so various and dissimilar. The problems in describing a person are essentially problems of knowing a person.
首先，你必须确立你的对手。重要的是要避免舒适的过度简化，转而钻研所有使我们的生活和需求如此多样、如此不同的模糊和顽固的身份与欲望问题。描述一个人的问题本质上就是了解一个人的问题。
One of the sad features of most close relationships is the decay of intimacy as a function of time, turmoil, and all the little misunderstandings that inevitably occur between people, leading them, year in and year out, toward the same tired conclusions. Conversation falters. Friendships fail.
大多数亲密关系的一个可悲特征是，随着时间、动荡和人们之间不可避免发生的小误解，亲密关系逐渐衰落，年复一年地将他们推向同样厌倦的结论。谈话停滞。友谊失败。
That said, allow me to concede that my brother, Hiram, is an incredible asshole. He's just a complete jerk. He finds your worst insecurities and then tortures you, until you'll do practically anything to escape his voice's dry wheezing and the spectacle of bony fists clutching that walker.
话虽如此，请允许我承认，我的兄弟Hiram是一个令人难以置信的混蛋。他就是一个彻底的混蛋。他找出你内心最深处的不安全感，然后折磨你，直到你几乎愿意做任何事来逃避他干瘪的喘息声和那个抓着助行器的骨感拳头的奇观。
"Take a look at yourself, Doug. Take an honest look at yourself standing there, with your hair falling in your eyes. You really could do with a trim and a shave." He paused, coughed, inhaled one of his racking breaths.
“看看你自己，Doug。诚实地看看站在那儿的你自己，头发落在眼睛里。你真的需要理个发刮个胡子了。”他停顿、咳嗽，吸了一口他那粗糙的呼吸。
He resumed, "You need some new clothes. Those clothes you're wearing don't even fit you. Who wears a corduroy jacket anymore? You don't even stand straight, Doug. You slouch. You've always slouched. You have the posture of a weak person."
他接着说：“你需要些新衣服。你穿的这些衣服根本不合身。现在还有谁穿灯芯绒夹克？你站都站不直，Doug。你总是驼着背。你有着弱者的姿态。”
I said to Hiram, "The fact that I haven't shaved this week means nothing. I only want to help. I want everybody to get along. I want all of us to be happy again."
我对Hiram说：“这周我没刮胡子什么也说明不了。我只想帮忙。我希望每个人都能和睦相处。我希望我们所有人都能再次快乐。”
How did this sound, woeful, tender? I should explain that in spite of antipathy toward our eldest brother, toward his more hateful manifestations, it was still not uncommon-- and I believe this has been true for each of us in our relations with the man-- to hope for some kindness or gentleness, even a hint of his admiration for the odd opinion or sentiment, whatever.
这话听起来怎么样，悲伤，温柔？我应该解释说，尽管我们对长兄有反感，对他那些更可恶的表现有反感，但这种情况并不罕见——而且我相信这对我们每个人与此人的关系中都是如此——去期待某种仁慈或温柔，哪怕是对某种奇特的观点或情感的赞赏，无论如何。
You see, in his presence, we felt like children, children caught in precisely those worst moments of growing up, those times of clear and terrifying appreciation of one's utter smallness in the world. And this smallness is excruciating to feel in adulthood, because it is a form of regression, and therefore, humiliating. For this reason, and in spite of mean feelings, in spite of everything, we all craved our aged brother's esteem.
你看，在他的面前，我们感觉像孩子，像被困在成长过程中最糟糕时刻的孩子，那些清楚且恐怖地意识到自己在世界上极其微小的时刻。这种微小在成年期感受起来极其痛苦，因为它是一种退化，因此是羞辱。出于这个原因，尽管有厌恶的感觉，尽管有种种一切，我们都渴望得到这位老兄弟的尊重。
He heaved himself up and gaped another painful breath. It hurt to listen to him. "It's a good thing father isn't around anymore to see what's become of you." I walked forward two steps and abruptly, dramatically, as if swooning, collapsed before Hiram's feet.
他撑起自己，又喘了一口气。“父亲不在了真是幸运，看不到你变成了什么样子。”我向前走了两步，突然戏剧性地，仿佛昏厥一般，倒在Hiram的脚下。
I dropped to my hands and knees and reached out for those broken lilies. Several pale blooms had come to rest directly atop Hiram's large, black wingtip shoes. I plucked up one, then another, and another ruined flower.
我跪倒在地，伸向那些破碎的百合花。几朵苍白的花朵刚好停在Hiram那双巨大、黑色的皮鞋上。我捡起一朵，又一朵，又一朵残破的花。
Donald Antrim, reading from his book, The Hundred Brothers.
Donald Antrim，朗读自他的书《百个兄弟》。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike, senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Alex Blumberg and Rachel Day.
嗯，我们的节目今天由Julie Snyder和我制作，Alix Spiegel和Nancy Updike参与，资深编辑Paul Tough，特约编辑Jack Hitt、Margy Rochlin，以及顾问Sarah Vowell。Alex Blumberg和Rachel Day提供制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
If you want to buy a cassette copy of our program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, phone number 312-832-3380. Again, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买我们节目的磁带副本，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，电话号码312-832-3380。再次重复，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是[email protected]。 《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who reminds you--
WBEZ管理监督Torey Malatia，他提醒你——
Your teeth are your greatest possession. You probably think your greatest possession is your johnson. But it's not your johnson. It's your teeth.
你的牙齿是你最大的财富。你可能认为你最大的财富是你的命根子。但不是你的命根子。是你的牙齿。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
We all love one another here. This whole room is full of love.
我们所有人都互相关爱。整个房间充满了爱。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。